samir sur les professeurs d'histoire des
relations internationales à l'université
de montréal bonsoir bonsoir
pourquoi d'abord à temps visé le pétrole
saoudien que ce soient les outils du
yémen où que ce soit l'iran peu importe
qu'ils se soient pourquoi on vise
précisément des installations
pétrolières
si la richesse de l'arabie saoudite et
l'arabie saoudite est en conflit en
guerre contre les en sarrau là où les
outils puis minutes qu'ils aillent poste
à leur façon ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il vise les installations
pétrolière de l'arabie saoudite
ils l'ont fait auparavant ils ont fait
au moins demain ils ont fait au mois
d'août
c'est la troisième attaque la plus
importante la plus spectaculaire mais
elle n'est pas hors norme ils ont déjà
envoyé des drones contre des
installations saoudienne parce qu'ils
subissent les bombardements saoudien
régulièrement et ils sont en état de
guerre avec l'arabie saoudite
pourquoi on identifie aujourd'hui l'iran
comme étant responsable messieurs car il
est dit mme se pâment paix aux
etats-unis le président tandis qu'il
semble que ce soient les iraniens
pourquoi on identifie lire alors ça
c'est le grand problème et c'est le
grand risque la situation actuelle c'est
de mêler de conflit le conflit que
l'arabie saoudite mènent contre le yémen
et le conflit des états unis et de
l'arabie saoudite contre les rangs il ya
aux états unis un courant et qui veut la
guerre avec contre lyon il y a l'arabie
saoudite qui veut cette guerre contre
l'iran donc il ya un danger que cette
attaque qui appartient à la guerre y
amène arabie saoudite deviennent soit
mêlé à un autre conflit beaucoup plus
grave celui là parce que les
conséquences seraient vraiment sérieuse
pour le
ainsi que le pétrole mondial mais est ce
qu'un lien entre le conflit yémen arabie
saoudite et l'iran il y a un lien
globale en ce sens que l'arabie saoudite
fait partie d'une coalition anti
iranienne et elle fait elle elle est en
conflit avec avec le yémen
mais ce n'est pas le même conflit ce
sont deux choses différentes
il est certain que le liant à puis le
gard où la houle et les outils mais ce
n'est pas d'un conflit sont deux deux
situations différentes 2 de terrains ou
de théâtre de conflits différents alors
là on voit aujourd'hui les conséquences
en tout cas on en parle on ne parle pas
que de ça il ya des conséquences
politiques géopolitiques
il ya des conséquences sur les pays ont
des conséquences économiques bien sûr
avec la hausse du prix du pétrole
comme on les évalue ses conséquences la
politique et économique les conséquences
de la situation actuelle ne sont pas
doit être relativisée c'est à dire qu'on
n'est pas en situation de crise
pétrolière en ce moment c'est une
secousse que le marché a subi en raison
de ses attaques
il a été remonté de 10 % mais là nous
soyons prêts s'il de 14 à 19% j'aurais
déjà 10% car s'est enrayée parce que
c'est la plus forte aux entraîneurs
s'étaient 19 sites et 10% de maintenance
à augmenter par la suite des violences
mais la situation est gérable gérable en
ce sens que les autres producteurs
augmentent peuvent augmenter leur
production l'arabie saoudite détient des
stocks très importants de la rabroue des
stocks de pétrole
les etats-unis ont des rêves et des
stocks stratégiques très important avec
cette cette situation peut être résorbé
par contre si cette situation et qui est
un échec pour l'arabie saoudite est
transformée en guerre contre l'iran
alors nous avons véritablement une crise
pétrolière
parce que ça ne serait plus une un 5 %
de la production mondiale
ce serait alors 33% production mondiale
qui seraient touchés donc faire très
attention que cette ce qui se passe en
ce moment ne se transforme pas en guerre
contre evian en attaque contrée ans et
ça ressemble à cela c'est vers cela
qu'on va
on voit bien train qui hésite il est
certainement poussé par les éléments des
va-t-en-guerre america mais lui sait
très bien que une guerre un conflit en
valais coûter très cher d'autant plus
qu'il veut se faire élire l'année
prochaine la vallée coûter très cher sur
le plan des prix du pétrole et coûter
très cher sur le plan guerrier
assurément militaire mais il est certain
que les états unis ont subi un choc
parce que la maman ça vous dire qui est
un moment américain n'a servi à rien
contre quelques drones un armement qui a
coûté des milliards de dollars il n'a
servi à rien contre des drones de
quelques milliers dollars et est ce que
c'est ça la nouvelle aujourd'hui dans le
france est de constater que l'arabie
saoudite à risques géopolitiques
important et donc qu'on va voir dans les
prix du pétrole une forme de primes qui
vont être associés à ce risque
géopolitique c'est à dire que l'arabie
saoudite n'est pas tout à fait en mesure
d'éviter cela je crois que vous mettez
le doigt sur la nouvelle de la journée
je pense qu'elle est même plus
importante que la question pétrolière
est là révèle la faiblesse de la vie
sauve dit sur le plan militaire et
l'inefficacité de l'armement américain
qu'elle possède
elle a dépensé des milliards de dollars
pour les systèmes patriot qui sont des
systèmes de défense côtière et n'ont
servi à rien et là c'est un révélateur
pour la région c'est un révélateur pour
israël qui est aussi armé de ce genre de
deux patriotes et la seconde à qui
surveille évidemment la situation de
très près sors bien que israël est lui
aussi vulnérable donc le je pense que
l'événement du jour c'est là la
révélation que l'arabie saoudite et son
ses soutiens américains ne sont pas
aussi puissants qu'on la porte comme un
tout le monde donc sa ligne par rapport
à cela les partenaires
les canada par exemple comment on
s'aligne par rapport à ce qui se passe
en ce moment
j'espère que le canada ait pris position
sur cette question là mais je jeu il
serait prudent que le canada ne prendre
pas une action militaire contre contre
l'iran parce qu'alors nous aurions une
crise une crise pétrolière qui nous
touchera directement parce qu'à ce
moment là il y aura une pénurie
en ce moment il n'y a pas de pénurie
mais il pourrait y en avoir un conflit
générale est déclenchée au moyen âge
samir saul merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soir j'en fais plaisir
vas-y